hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to frightened pixels in the
horror game there's not much else to say
I've been trying to do this intro for a
while can't come up with the right words
it's Friday you just woke up before 8
a.m.
seems like you will be late for school
once you woke up light in your room went
out seconds later you heard a really
loud scream what happened
good thing that you locked yourself in
your room today but where is the key you
came back home really late in a bit
drunk
kids these days like to partay
The Scream was so terrifying that it
looks like no school for today
not until you find out what happened
that's a little bit of an awkward intro
I'm not sure what the story is gonna be
if that's what it's all about
well alrighty then I thought I was
reached Oh bit more than I was and I'm
Darth Vader apparently okay
okay there's definitely more immersive
than the graphics old Bo is gonna be and
the grammar - come on look very serious
with this canoe there I got a Crouch I
forgot okay right what's in here I sure
I'm glad I'm a paranoid douche and
locked myself in my own room so those
are some cool jams on the radio I locked
myself in my room with a box lights no
work Dory is locked because somehow this
is a college dorm where that happens I
can only assume I'm a college kid
because I screwed shouldn't be drinking
got it okay here we go
hello is anybody in my own home
which is apparently bigger than I
thought a college student could afford
and with a lot more buck
what you want to run that by me again
cuz I didn't actually see anything okay
okay hmm I wonder why all the lights no
work Rob because some demonic and
monstrosity is gonna kill me oh okay
hello it's my neighbor nope still no
work I should probably just stop trying
Oh No
is that blood that looks like blood I
know blood when I see and that's a lot
of bleeding blue blood good this isn't
my morning radio Phil
batteries batteries seemed oh I get it
they're all cumulative but for some
reason I don't know why hmm that is a
lot of blood wandering why maybe the
reason could jump out at me okay
as a weird house I can lie
I'm just gonna charge blindly in
whatever may happen to me will happen
carpe diem seize the scares carpe diem
seize the dick
all right either
okay so I need to find key Oh nope this
one's open
sorry hello I sure do have a lot of
knives oh what's in here a head I hope
so
no apparently not okay well that was all
a lot nothing glad that happened okay
trying really hard to keep this steady
because it is very sensitive on the
thing and it has been a while since I
played Leica
pixelated style or games of blue I got a
key to what I have no idea but it's key
it's definitely key shaped key like this
this okay here we go good oh sure oh hey
how's it going in here why is there just
another key on the wall okay cool glad
glad glad okay wait a minute
this wasn't here before the bunch of
bull going on here who boxed me an onion
govern'd get out of here
yep thank you okay still wondering where
all this blood came from
I thought I saw something I thought that
was like the arms or something you can
never tell with these pixelated games
hello
also where's my front door that's what I
really want to know maybe this was my
front door over here the large house I'm
your worst nightmare your parents are
not coming back don't look behind you
will be dead soon too
okay barely saw anything Oh
after searching the whole house you
found out that nobody is inside what the
hell happened where is mom and dad why
are you getting drunk where is your
little sister you have to head outside
to see if they are there only one thing
is sure something really bad is
happening Oh Oh could you tell that from
all the blind and the weird box is and
the weird demon maybe all is pretty
hello how's it going
you're not tiny enough oh my goodness
it's tiny bug Steve and tiny bugs Tina
how you doing I'll be back for you later
you have some weird smoke drifting off
to you but that's okay all right
feel choked up my own spit there Jesus
you're gonna do that to me buy me dinner
first ease alrighty then
cool nothing here but cat turds oh
that's comforting sound I'm glad that's
there can I go down the slide that sure
would be fun okey-dokey then
uh why why with all the blood was this
weird person shaped hole in the ground
well I better dance on his grave coming
out on lap a low hum be boundary log its
music to dance this is my jam how to
deal of it on talking no no oh the puppy
who no poops are poachers did that's a
legal legally like Patrick Starr I'm not
sure what I saw there oh this is
comforting I'm sure we're glad we have a
shed full of demons I opened it
is co2
let me breathing better than me
breathing
turkey here no but there is shovel Oh
what am I gonna dig up what am I gonna
dig what's in the grave oh great okay
I'll be back with the corpse of
something I want you to dig with me get
with this Oh No OOP sirs I think that is
Oh low-res pooper scoopers oh he was the
best won't be Whomper it was the best
won't be one person out fear this demon
now the team has made a person I'll just
be mad
how's that horror movie and someone
killed my dog you better damn better be
sure that demon better run quick ain't
nothing gonna stop me from getting to it
okay you went outside you found your dog
who is such an animal to do these kinds
of things to innocent little puppies
that's what I asked something or
somebody is trying to tell you something
or maybe is trying to kill you you found
huge amounts of bloodstains on the
ground in the shed and in your house
they lead straight to your basement you
have to go there your parents must still
be somewhere oh this demon is gonna get
a whole lot of dead I mean I'm dead
serious if any sort of demon monstrosity
entity I don't care if it was a vampire
werewolf it would be fisticuffs time for
that douche nozzle you
date
okay cool thanks thanks for the update
from the local news why was this
covering up this blood it's not like it
boo wait a minute
ah I see so how do I open said thing
through here oh it's just a fuse on the
ground
no apparel is whole lot of nothing one
fuses minutes right there pick it up
dingus okay so I need to find a fools
think I got a lot of batteries you're
thinking this key over here all right
Open Sesame who's gonna get some who
wants some I will murder your face I
will murder all of your faces seriously
you want some I'm ready to throw down
its own its own like Donkey Kong it's
where you sacrifice my parents you
bastard
huh don't face me like a man like a man
what's up there
okay shitty shitty I know someone's
scattin away over there the demonic
voices of whispers come on yep I can't
jump very high I'm very weak come on
with this ball in this crap Oh
God don't go that way you son of a
nugget huh oh there we go
okay oh yes this is exactly what I've
always wanted
ma there we go there we go all right
what's up here
nothing nothing whole lot of nothing
what a bunch of baloney okay so I got to
find like a square to refuse something
that's a mess
no okay well what then is this I need to
put this over here for some reason yes
yes this was shoving Tajimi okay so okay
Oh Oh there was a demonic circle there
where there was a pentagram
I don't know the Wiccans will be upset
but I think I know what I need
how it'll be even more mad damn it
oh I can't go back up okay I thought I
needed to like get the corpse of my dog
and then put it back there that would
have been really really sad I would have
been very upset about that but
apparently I just need to find Oh out
there I saw it I saw I saw it with my
eyeballs
I saw eye-shine get that there I can't
jump on that because I'm too stubby I
didn't I skip flagged a guy can't jump
yeah yeah look there we go yeah give
give give give give yeah we go I got it
okay
time to throw down you ready Damon you
ready for John Cena
oh oh okay then well scuse me all right
John Cena this Sunday night you are in
the ring oh hello hello all right then
okay doors step doors a stack historic
broken so uh
Wimbley Buble oh it's a number nine one
seven all right good enough for me oh
it's a series of the other one must add
numbers to I thought it was just a
mirage on it
okay BRB don't worry you never have to
wait long for John six four one six four
one I think that is six four six six
four oh I won't forget because you know
who never forgets John okay
I know six four one nine one seven
oh well then as you expected somebody
broke the fuse to switch off the power
then you found the secret passage what
the hell is going on there's no other
way than by finding out by yourself okay
cool
okay where am I now who are some oh well
sure are a lot batteries down here don't
be there boobity boobity boo you ready
for the Thunder you ready for the
wrestle doom you ready for unlock steel
cage match with none other than WWE
Champion John Cena
must be the Undertaker
plan all this you made it personal
Undertaker Oh secret is revealed how in
one way and who did what to who and how
why was this ego revealed how did I get
a Luger reveal how what did I do okay
guys okay I can't jump up here now oh
good I can't get up there anymore well
whoop-dee-do for me
I go up here okay nope this led nowhere
okay glad that happened
oh here we go I got it okay ready
who's gonna go down who a chainsaw I'll
take that
yes please can I have that oh okay
it's about to go to the Thunder
I'll [ __ ] you with these boxes got the
physics is just horrible
oh wow
okay so uh yeah so uh so what about this
it's a lot about all this
I'm glad this is all works how I wanted
to what the [ __ ] just go over there son
of a [ __ ] just go
oh Jesus criminy Christmas mother
a piece of
was there not a reason to come back here
oh man it's like more box to spawn out
of the darkness Jesus it's not pit of
health boxes I can't even break him get
out of my way Jesus holy crap get out of
my way [ __ ] boxes okay was there
nothing back here those there was
nothing back there was no point to come
back here there was no point at all it's
absolutely no point oh wow okay all
right okay all right great
nothing in here oh here we go whoa what
was that
okay so someone was chopping down a tree
that's all that's all I heard I didn't
hear anything out of the ordinary there
all I did was get a key out of it which
is great for me I do on some awesome oh
okay I'm here cuz that's where the blood
trail leads that's where I'm gonna go
some dumb goober do is this
are those spanking hands those mannequin
hands or something oh wow
they're actually just body parts never
mind okay now we're getting somewhere
now we're getting somewhere now I'm
liking it battery here I'll ignore that
clipping for now I'll ignore that don't
get me stuck
there nothing there they're nice body
parts they're nice assortment I like the
arrangement is my parents like the
murderers here like this is our house
pretty much I mean maybe I'm just really
drunk or someone spiked my drink but
pretty sure I walked into my own house
probably probably he's got to be like a
my parts
then is a little more than a little
bizarre uh you know could be just a
misunderstanding could be an art project
or something locked
alright here we go this is the real door
this is the one I really
okay hello anybody here it's a person
that killed my dog here cuz that's all I
really want to talk to all righty then
wonder if this is where my long-lost
brother of which my family doesn't talk
about lived cuz that seems to be what's
happening here that are this in serious
cannibal isn't going on oh boy
bricks raids okay now what
yes I go back alright
it's kindest concerning that nothing has
happened for a while I'm feeling I'm
gonna happen can you open please thank
you
can you okay all right then fine that's
how we're gonna work this
who's here who's here
Ricky bricks no no no no no no
I really man you got the sound down you
got the sound design down I like it I
like it it's got what's fun it's got a
hood speed I open this why can't I open
this one this one's not open about why
is our not open about why is our not
orbital oh no open it
alright fine I'll go over this hello oh
boy
that looks fun I'm going to just carry
on who's in there with my other cage who
needs to be fed that you bring there
might be something in there well that's
good mmm
Dukey I'm just gonna I can't see
anything
so I'm assuming there's nothing
all righty then now it's cool oh good a
giant pipe that I can walk into I always
love wandering into a big steel butt
hole okay well that's nothing I'm
assuming that's my oh hi mom yes dear
son now wake up you're late for school
thanks mom you weirdo I had a nightmare
mom is everything all right ah
the nightmares oh hey let's go in there
okay all right that was hmm it was it
had a lot of good points and then it had
a lot of bad points because one the
pixilated style works for certain
certain recipes like there's obviously a
right way to do it in wrong way to do it
for some reason this one wasn't exactly
the right way to do it because in the
end it's like what I don't like about
horror games which is a key hunter like
it's its progression but it's still
linear hallway you're trying to find a
key and you're trying to go back but you
know it's still like it's still just a
very linear progression is making to do
a scavenger hunt instead of actually
getting into the story so it kind of
distracts from that like
why is everything locked buying the key
that's conveniently placed over there
but there was a lot of good about it in
that the atmosphere did give a lot of
creep factor when I wasn't distracted
from going to find key or worrying about
one thing or another being stupid with
job like it the atmosphere did get to me
I felt the creep happening like when it
was just allowing me to wander forward
into the darkness like that was really
cool I liked that part and then I liked
that but then the weird storytelling
between the like loading screens and
then the just the one paragraph of this
your motivation go you know instead of
like building up to it in some way you
know it's it's it had a lot of flaws and
laughington
some weird bizarre I don't know what to
tell you but the pixelated style does
work for some I don't think it worked
well for this one but the sound design
was really good I liked it a lot it was
very very good
but a gamer overall it didn't scare me
all that much because it didn't give me
a chance to be scared like you like
scaring like it's all on a personal
level when it comes to horror game
because it's not about the game that
scares you it's about you having fears
it's your fears that need to be
reflected in the game and so when you're
going in there your mind needs to create
up its own phobias so the game itself
like is like a vehicle it's a channel
for which you to be scared and it's a
channel for you to reveal your own
weaknesses that's what really makes it
cool so this one had a lot of good
things sound design was and if there was
more freedom to allow me to go around
and discover the mystery by myself it
would have been better I think so that's
just my opinion though so let me know
what you think in the comments below if
you have tips for how the developer
could improve this formula or do a
little better next time let them know in
the comments below or go to his page
give him some constructive criticism not
bad criticism because that doesn't get
anyone anywhere so thank you everybody
so much for watching check out the other
scare games I play check out mine
aired a pixelated nightmare and that was
like the original pixelated horror game
that I playing is very very good down
there way early in my channel years and
years ago I played that one so thank you
everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video after you help Burley